You are the most corrupt President in the history of Spain,
more corrupt than any of any party.
You are the paradigm of corruption in politics,
because you are stealing from the Spanish
the most precious thing for the Spanish.
I repeat,
gentlemen,
1 amnestiing another in exchange for his votes to stay in power,
against his words,
against the courts that condemned them,
against the laws that protect the
Spanish people and against the Spanish people.
You would be the bad guy in any novel,
in any series,
in any movie,
The most corrupt,
the most villainous and the most in.
Mr..
There is no way to hide this reality.
Look,
you are able,
if suddenly gets an election,
to tell us all that it is because you have not
And again to wrap yourself in the flag of Spain,
because we do not forget how you came to politics in the American way,
with 1 gigantic flag behind you,
appearing as a couple as if he were the Kennedy of Pozuelo de Alarcón.
You are the President,
Mr.,
with the support of those who have murderers on their lists,
with the support of those who have murdered their socialist comrades,
with the support of those who killed people.
That is to say,
once again you give what belongs to all Spaniards,
the National dignity,
in exchange for yours.